♪♪
Narrator:
NASA PUT TOGETHER A TEAM
OF THEIR BEST
AND BRIGHTEST ENGINEERS
TO DESIGN A SPACECRAFT CAPABLE
OF EXPLORING THE UNIQUE
AND TECHNICALLY CHALLENGING
OCEANS OF THIS LIQUID WORLD.
♪♪
AND, AFTER A NUMBER
OF FALSE STARTS AND DEAD ENDS,
THEY CAME UP WITH THIS --
A SUBMARINE.
Oleson: I WAS READING "TWENTY
THOUSAND LEAGUES UNDER THE SEA,"
AND THOUGHT, YOU KNOW,
"TITAN HAS THESE WONDERFUL
GROUPS OF SEAS.
WHAT'S UNDERNEATH THERE?"
IF YOU CAN GET
BELOW THE SURFACE OF THE SEA
AND GET ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO THE BOTTOM IN CERTAIN AREAS
AND ACTUALLY TOUCH THE SILT
THAT'S ON THE BOTTOM
AND SAMPLE IT AND LEARN
WHAT THAT'S MADE OF,
IT'LL TELL YOU SO MUCH ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT YOU'RE IN.
BUT, IF YOU HAVE A BOAT
THAT JUST DRIVES ON THE SURFACE,
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET A PROBE
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE BOTTOM,
GET THAT SAMPLE ALL THE WAY BACK
UP TO THE SURFACE AND SAMPLE IT
REALLY BECOMES
AN INTRACTABLE PROBLEM.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS
THAT COULD GO WRONG DOING THAT.
AND, INSTEAD, WE SAID,
"IF WE CAN ENCAPSULATE
EVERYTHING TOGETHER
IN A SUBMARINE,
THEN WE COULD GO RIGHT DOWN
AND DO THAT SAMPLING
AND COME ALL THE WAY BACK
UP TO THE SURFACE."
♪♪
Narrator: BUT SAILING
A LARGE ONE-TUB SUB
AROUND TITAN'S SUPER-COLD,
METHANE-RICH SEAS
ISN'T WITHOUT ITS PROBLEMS.
FORTUNATELY,
NASA HAS THE TECHNOLOGY
TO REPLICATE CONDITIONS
ON THE FREEZING MOON,
AND THIS IS IT.
INSIDE THIS HUGE TANK,
SCIENTISTS CAN SAFELY
AND ACCURATELY MIX UP
THE HIGHLY VOLATILE COCKTAIL
OF CHEMICALS
THAT MAKE UP THE ATMOSPHERE
OF THE HUGE MOON.
THEY'VE DISCOVERED
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
OF TITAN'S METHANE SEAS IS
THAT THEY'RE RICH IN NITROGEN,
AND THAT COULD MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO MANEUVER.
Paul: THERE COULD BE SO MUCH
NITROGEN DISSOLVED IN THE SEA
THAT, WHEN THE PROPELLERS
TURN IN OUR JETS,
IT MIGHT JUST MAKE
A LOT OF BUBBLES
AND NOT BE ABLE TO PUSH
AGAINST THE LIQUID.
SO WE'RE DOING ANALYSIS NOW
AND WE HOPE TO DO SOME TESTING
IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THAT SHOWS US WHAT HAPPENS
IF YOU SPIN A PROPELLER
IN LIQUID METHANE,
IN LIQUID ETHANE, WITH LOTS
OF NITROGEN DISSOLVED IN IT,
AND CAN YOU GET
ANY THRUST OUT OR NOT?
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION TO ANSWER.
[PINGING]
Narrator: THE SUB WILL BE
PACKED FULL
OF SCIENTIFIC INSTRUMENTS
AND TEEMING WITH CAMERAS.
BUT THERE'S ONE THING
THE SCIENTISTS FEEL
WILL MAKE THE MISSION,
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
[ BEEP ]
Paul: THAT FIRST PICTURE.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
THAT FIRST PICTURE
FROM A SUBMARINE,
FROM ANYBODY'S SUBMARINE,
ON THE SURFACE OF A SEA
ON ANOTHER PLANET IN OUR
SOLAR SYSTEM CHANGES THE WORLD.
I MEAN, THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT NONE OF US
HAVE EVER SEEN BEFORE.
THAT IS TRUE DISCOVERY.
THAT IS WHY WE DO ANY OF THIS.
AND THAT WOULD BE AWESOME --
THAT FIRST PICTURE, ALONE,
WOULD MAKE THIS ENTIRE
MISSION WORTH IT.